Ein Alienangriff auf dem Planeten Erde. Es ist eine Invasion, es geht ums nackte Überleben. Offenbar wussten die Ausserirdischen genau, wie sie uns am härtesten treffen können. Deutschland sucht Guido Kanz. Grosse Suche, wo ist Guido? Die Ausserirdischen haben als erstes Guido Kanz eliminiert. Warum reist ein ausserirdisches Raumschiff quer durchs Universum, um Guido Kanz auszulöschen? Thais meinte, sie kümmert sich da mal drum, dass sie ist weg. So, Gott hab sie selig. Können wir das überleben? Ja, aber es zeigt auch, dass wir das nicht übertreiben. Und das ist genau die Stimme, die ich meine. Es ist ernst, es ist wirklich ernst. Und genau, wir übertreiben nicht NTV oder was auch immer, vielleicht ist es auch so Phoenix oder so. Phoenix, ja, so alte Reruns, das kannst du jedes Jahr senden, das ist kein Problem. Die Lage ist ernst, die Lage ist verzweifelt, der Krieg hat begonnen gegen die Aliens. Da bleibt auch nicht Zeit, um Hallo zu sagen. Da bleibt nicht, nein, da müssen wir sofort alle zusammen trommeln, wir müssen sofort an Losschlagen, es muss losgehen.
Trotzdem vielen, vielen Dank an Susi, die hier quasi die Whistleblowerin gespielt hat für diesen erbarmungslosen Alienangriff, der seit vielen, vielen Tagen über uns herein prasselt.
Wir kommen kaum noch zur Ruhe.
Stefan Tietze, ich lache, ich lache laut.
Ich kann nur noch lachen, was soll ich noch machen, ich kann nur noch lachen.
Kämpfen, nimm die Waffe in die Hand, nimm die Faust in die Hand, zieh die Boxschuhe an.
Ich habe Kriegsdienst verweigert, ich habe Zivildienst geleistet,
ich kann nicht kämpfen, ich habe es nie gelernt.
Ich habe gelernt, wie man Leute in einem Rollstuhl die Treppe
runter trägt. Das habe ich gelernt in einem
mehrtägigen Lehrgang. Du kannst auch für den Sanitätsdienst
einsteigen. Wir brauchen einfach
Leute, die jetzt geschlossen
gegen die, und es ist wirklich
kurz vor zwölf, das meine ich ganz im Ernst,
denn New Jersey, die Drohnen, niemand weiss, woher sie kommen, alles ist da voller Drohnen.
Und dann gefällt mir auch immer diese Karte, diese Weltkarte, wo die UFO-Sichtungen kartografiert werden mit so Pinnadeln.
Und ganz USA ist voll und der Rest interessiert sich nicht wirklich. Entweder für den Himmel, also
entweder wir gucken alle, als
alle anderen Länder zu, oft einfach nach unten
und nicht nach oben in den Himmel.
Stimmt. Ich finde gut,
dass du direkt in die Aufarbeitung
gehst, dass du noch bevor der Krieg entschieden
ist, in die Aufarbeitung gehst. Wie konnte es soweit
kommen? Du schreibst sofort die ersten reißerischen
Geschichtsbücher. Das ist immer meine Frage. Wie konnte es soweit kommen?
Wieso sind wir jetzt hier, wo wir sind? Du hast irgendwie komplett USA voll und dann nochmal zwei bei Osnabrück.
Und das ist dann auch so, okay, ist das Zufall?
Haben die sich, war das eine Art Fahrgemeinschaft der Aliens?
Haben die sich in Warp-Strom beteilt?
Wetterballon ist dann immer die Antwort, wo ich mich frage, was ist das überhaupt und warum gibt es das?
Ist der Wetterballon konstant in der Luft?
Oder sagt man, ich habe keinen fucking Plan, was gratis Wetter ist? Alle Leute schragen die Tagesschau. Die gleichgeschalteten Medien behaupten immer, es handele sich dabei um einfache Wetterballons. Es sind einfache Wetterballons. Schauen Sie, ich zeige Ihnen, das ist mein E-Mail-Postfach. Zeigen Sie mir das E-Mail-Postfach. Das ist mein E-Mail-Postfach, schauen Sie mal.
Tagesschau, N24, Galileo Mystery.
Alle wollen wissen, was das fucking Wetter ist.
Der Mann wollte uns seine geheimen UFO-Akten nicht zeigen.
Ich habe sie euch alle gezeigt.
Und so bleibt die Frage, handelt es sich um harmlose Wetterballons oder sind es in der Tat über Osnabrück todbringende Aliens?
Nein, es sind immer noch Wetterballons, es sind immer die gleichen Wetterballons. Wir haben sie extra pink angemalt mit freundlichen Gesichtern, damit alle wissen, freundlich nett... Pinke, schwule Aliens. Nein, nein, nein, stopp. Sie verbreiten den Vogue-Virus. Nein, nein, okay, so, nein, also, falls Sie das Wetter wissen wollen, können Sie bleiben, ansonsten muss ich Sie bitten zu gehen.
Morgen wird heiter.
Ah, okay. Das wissen Sie woher? Von den Aliens? Nein, vom Wetterballon. Ich habe noch nie mehr im Leben Wetterballon gesehen. Ich stelle mir den vor wie ein Heissluftballon mit so Antennen dran. Kugelrund. Ich glaube, das ist der Unterschied zwischen Personenheißluftballonsfahrt und Wetterballonsfahrt,
ist, dass der Personenheißluftballonsfahrt
diese Tropfenform, diese Hodenform,
dieses wirklich runtersackende,
langgezogene
Heißluftballonsform, wogegen der Wetterballon
hat sich für die klassische Kugel entschieden,
die ja für den Personenverkehr
undenkbar ist. Absolut.
Warum? Also da kommen wir.
Das ist meine Frage, weil warum? Na, es gibt eine Ausnahme. Es gibt den Weltballon in Berlin. Ja, Berlin, der hohe Seil, aber der ist am Seil. Der ist am Draht, am heißen Draht. Und ich habe lange in der Nähe gewohnt und mir oft vorgestellt, wie ich ihn zerstöre, wie ich den Draht kappe, wie ich diese armen Menschen, die armen Touristen ihrem eigenen Schicksal überlasse. Und dann würden sich alle fragen, das ist ja so ein, das ist diese Art milde Terroranschläge, die ich spannend finde. Vermisse, ja, die vermisse ich. Vermissen ist ein starkes Wort. Nee, aber so diese harmlosen Terrorangriffe, die jetzt erstmal nichts machen, Sternchen, vielleicht sterben die Leute im Weltwetterballon dabei. Aber das ist so, wo man sich so fragt, gegen wen ist es jetzt ein Zeichen? Ich finde, ein guter Wo man seinen Twitter-Account durchgeht, um herauszufinden, so wie bei Luigi Mangione, wo man sich fragt, auf wessen Seite stand er jetzt? Und dann guckt man sich diese Tat an, okay, er hat diese Familie in diesem Weltballon abgeschnitten, die sind jetzt immer noch, sind sie gerade über Südafrika, diese Familie, man versucht sie da runterzuholen vom Himmel. Und du bist in Gewahrsam und das ganze Internet streitet sich, was deine Aussage war. Ich finde es wichtig, gerade bei solchen Anschlägen, dass man auch eine gewisse Botschaft aber nicht zu leicht macht. Also die Leute sollen schon arbeiten. Ich würde ein Bekennerschreiben machen
und dann schreiben, es ist leicht
wie die Luft, aber sinkt trotzdem
auf den Grund der Erde.
Die Nase.
Okay, es ist die Nase. Gut, ah, fuck, okay.
Was hat keinen Rücken,
aber kann dennoch nicht stehen.
Und man denkt, die Gesellschaft.
Nee, du hast
dann wirklich sowas, es hat es kann fliegen, hat aber keine Flügel. So, sowas. Und dann alle, die ganzen Fortunisten, alle reiben sich die Kinn. Aber ganz unter uns, wäre das nicht ein gutes Zeichen gegen die Springerpresse? Hat die Welt jetzt nicht Elon Musk so ein Interview geben lassen oder so Platz gegeben in der Welt für AfD-Werbung? Kann man da jetzt nicht mal aus Spaß jetzt den Weltleistungsballon durchschneiden? Ja, aber gäbe es nicht in, also mein Problem ist, das ist eine einmalige Nummer. Du schneidest ein, du kappst einmal das Kabel und danach nie wieder, weil danach wird das wahrscheinlich nicht nochmal aufgebaut werden. Doch, mit einer dickeren Kette. Die knuren den nicht einfach nochmal dran, weil die Leute sagen, ja, den hier, den hier, dass ich da draufgehe, wenn das schon mal so eine Katastrophe war. Aber jetzt würde ich sagen, lass uns alles so Marie Kondo-mässig untersuchen. Die hat ja diese Regel, alles, was ihr die letzten drei Monate nicht gebraucht habt oder so, kann weg. Und das ist auch eine gute Regel für unsere Städte. Alles, was jetzt nach einem Terroranschlag nicht noch mal neu aufgebaut worden würde, kann erst mal generell weg. Erst mal alles zerstören und dann gucken, was man wieder wirklich aufbauen will. Was man aufbauen würde, das man gedanklich durchspielt. Wenn du sagst, dieser Weltballon würde nicht noch mal neu Ich glaube, das Problem ist, der Weltballon ist zu einzigartig. So nach 9-11 hat niemand gesagt, ich werde nie wieder fliegen. So, weil, wie soll man sonst von A nach B kommen? Wie kommst du sonst nach Hannululu? Keine Chance. Aber niemand sagt, nachdem der Weltballon, nachdem da zwölf Menschen in den Höhen tot gerissen wurden, da sagt man, ach so, ja dann gehe ich halt nie wieder in den Weltballon. Das ist ein relativ leichtes Opfer. Das können die allermeisten Menschen der Gesellschaft. Wenn du Fan davon bist, dann weiss ich nicht, du hast wenig Alternativen, das ist zwar, was ich sage. Richtig, richtig. Du hast, wenn du den Weltballon liebst und dann machen das aber Leute, also du kommst da, bist da hochgelassen und dann wirst du runtergeholt. Genau, dann wirst du wieder runtergeholt, ja. Ja, runtergezogen, ganz großartig. Wir wollen jetzt hier nichts und nichts anstiften oder so. Nein, stopp, stopp. Ich meine nur, weil du gerade sagst, es ist gerade kontrovers rund um die Welt. Wir wissen ja nicht, ob das der beste Zeitpunkt ist. Du willst ja, das wäre bei Aktien. Du weißt ja nicht, sind die in einem Monat noch schlimmer? Könntest du noch besseres Zeichen setzen nächsten Monat? Oder machst du es jetzt? Das ist so, wie wenn du Hitler umgebracht hättest 1934, das ist so okay, hm?
Also ich meine, es war nicht cool, aber es war jetzt so, wo du denkst,
okay, also
verstehst du, was ich meine, so du weisst nicht,
soll ich noch ein Ja geben, genau,
es war nicht Peak, es war nicht, wo du sagst, okay,
das ist wirklich der Punkt, wo es
dann auch gerechtfertigt ist,
ne, verstehst du, was ich meine?
Also, jetzt an alle Zeitreisenden, falls jetzt ihr könnt auch 34 zuschlagen. Ist kein Thema. Der Fakt, dass es noch niemand verhindert hat und wir noch in unserer Dimension, in der wir leben, das Ganze hatten,
dieses Kapitel. Aber meinst du, es wird
noch jemand ihn getötet haben?
Nee, dann wäre es ja schon passiert. What happened happened.
What happened will happen and has happened.
Ja, du sagst immer so Sachen, aber du
belegst sie nicht. Doch, Tenet,
mit dem Film Tenet. Es kann ja sein, dass wir
morgen aufwachen und Hitler ist
komplett ausradiert aus allem, aus der
Weltgeschichte. Wüssten wir das dann? Würden wir merken so, sag mal, sorry, war da nicht was? Ich habe auf Wikipedia mal geguckt. Ja, das ist der Nielsen-Mandela-Effekt. Da war zwar, ich bin mir so sicher, dass es Mandela-Effekt heißt, aber okay. Das ist der Nielsen-Mandela-Effekt, das habe ich nicht schon. Ja, ich bin mir, okay. Aber ich habe nachgeguckt, 42 Olympia, so. Die Sowjetunion und USA halten sich die Hände und Deutschland. Guck mal die Ländergrenzen von Deutschland an. Locker, normal, wie immer, wie immer. Danzig, wie man es kennt, wie man es liebt. Danzig ist dabei. Danzig, wie es lacht. Wie es lebt, wie wir es auch nicht missen wollen.
Nein, der Preisgau ist französisch. Königsberg ist alles da, alles, wo es sein soll. Und dann ist halt so die Frage, würde man das überhaupt merken? Also welche Schrecken wurden alle schon ausradiert, die wir gar nicht wissen, dass sie ausradiert wurden? Vielleicht gab es ja Ultra-Hitler, der noch schlimmer war, wo die Zeitenreisenden gesagt haben, okay, okay, okay, von mir aus Hitler, aber erstmal Ultra-Hitler, Peak-Hitler und dann den rausnehmen und von dem wissen wir gar nichts. Oder diese Alternative, die wir jetzt haben, ist die beste. Wenn man Hitler umgebracht hätte, wäre jemand gekommen, der noch viel Schlimmeres gemacht hätte. Und das ist schon die beste, also wir sind auf diesem schmalen Grat zwischen furchtbaren Armageddon-Genozid-Horror-Sachen und wir sind auf der immer noch schlimmen, aber besten Linie durchgeschlittert. Aber jetzt warte mal, die Aliens, die jetzt gerade angreifen, auf uns einhämmern, kann es nicht sein, dass die, das Licht hat so lange gebraucht, das Licht vom Zweiten Weltkrieg, die Sonne scheint, geht eines Tages auf, scheint auf Stalingrad und das Licht wird reflektiert von Stalingrad und fliegt durch das ganze Universum, braucht viele, viele Jahrzehnte, um auf dem Alienplaneten anzukommen und dann fliegen die los und sagen, das müssen wir verhindern, und kommen jetzt an und ballern uns jetzt weg, obwohl das Ergebnis schon vorbei ist. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Vielleicht ist das die Reaktion. Das ist generell das Problem mit Space Travel, was ich sehe, weil das Licht braucht ja, also unserer Sonne, der nahegelegenste Stern, der ist so fucking nah und es dauert acht Minuten das Licht hierhin. Und dann wie viele Lichtjahre manche Sterne entfernt sind, da hinzukommen, dann sieht da alles ganz anders aus. Acht Minuten von der Sonne auf die Erde. Dauert das Licht, ja. Das heisst, eigentlich ist die Sonne schon untergegangen. In der Zukunft. Wenn wir sie gerade untergehen sehen, ist sie eigentlich schon weg. Nee, du denkst das wieder ganz falsch. Du denkst mal wieder komplett falsch. Es ist aber auch keine konstruktive Lernumgebung hier, finde ich, um ein bisschen Feedback in deine Richtung zu geben. Florin, du denkst mal wieder wie ein Idiot. Okay, ja. Wundervolle alle anderen in der Klasse haben das gut gemacht. Aber Florin, du denkst mal wieder wie der grösste Vollidiot, okay? Nur, dass du Bescheid weisst. Also konstruktive Kritik, damit du demnächst nicht wie ein Vollidiot dastehst. Und dann übrigens ein Neujahrsvorsatz jetzt für mich ist, und das ist für uns alle, wir verstehen den Mond falsch. Ist das ein Vorsatz? Also der Vorsatz ist, den Mond falsch zu verstehen oder diesen Irrtum zu korrigieren? Und den richtig zu verstehen. Okay, verständnis für den Mond. Weil, wie stellst du dir die Bahn des Mondes um die Sonne vor? Wie stellst du dir das vor? Tief. Ringelig, ne? Spiralig. Weil der Umkreis uns ja ständig. Ständig. Ja, einmal im Monat, ne? So zwölf Kreise in der Umlaufbahn, würde ich sagen. Genau, nein. Es ist ein ganz gerader Kreis. Ach so, auch um, ja. Und das ist so, und das denkt man nicht, und das, ich finde, dass unser engster Freund ist, kosmisch. Okay, du magst den Mond nicht, aber ... Ich bin kein Fan. Ja, aber das ist so schlecht begründet. War nie ein Fan. Kein Fan von Eben Flut. Du sagst, das steht auf deinem T-Shirt, es steht auf deiner Website. Kein Fan vom Mond. Du hast einen Bumpersticker auf deinem Auto, kein Fan vom Mond. Ich fände es okay, wenn er die Nacht beherrschen würde, aber er zeigt sich am Tag. Und da sage ich Stopp. Die Sonne, Stopp, die Sonne hat sich noch nie nachts gezeigt, also sollte sich der Mond auch nicht tagsüber zeigen. Aber der Mond... Hau ab! Es ist nicht deine Tageszeit! Es ist nicht deine Tageszeit! Es ist nicht deine Tageszeit! Ja, das hast du schon mal gesagt. Perfekt. Es funktioniert für mich nicht. Deswegen, weg mit dem Mond. Du magst den Daylight Moon nicht. Nee, schieß den weg. Ich hoffe, dass die Aliens hinwegballern, dass irgendeine Rakete oder irgendein Laserstrahl von den Aliens wirklich den Mond mitnehmen. Bei mir ist es etwas anders. Ich denke mir, wenn ich den Mond am Tag sehe, denke ich
an unsere Freunde auf der anderen Seite
der Erde, die gerade Nacht haben
und keinen Mond. Ja, und wir haben
den. So wie wenn du dir was ausleihst,
du hast irgendwie die
Dinner for One CD, DVD, an Weihnachtsabend
bei dir liegen. Sag mal, wer von euch hat eigentlich
eine Dinner for One CD und du siehst sie
bei dir? Und du sagst nichts. Nee, sagst nichts. Genau so ist das so. Die sind im Dunkeln, laufen gegen die Wand, fallen irgendwie die Klippe runter und du denkst dir, scheiße, ich hab den Mond gerade. Ich sag aber nichts. Ich sag aber nichts. Ne, wir sagen nichts. Das stimmt, ja. Das habe ich ein schlechtes Gewissen immer. Ich denke, boah, die bräuchten den jetzt mehr. Ich finde es doppelt gemoppelt. So, und das denke ich mir, das schlechte Gewissen musst nicht du haben,
sondern der Mond. Der Mond hat sich ja entschieden,
so, ach, lass die Trottel da runterfallen, lass die
da irgendwie der Dunkelheit bleiben, ich geh jetzt mal
schön auf die Sonnenseite, lass mich auch mal schön
die Sonne auf dem Bauch scheinen.
Ja, ich möchte nur... Mond, Arschmond.
Nein, das nimmst du zurück?
Doch. Das ist so
antiintellektuell dummes Gelaber.
Ich will das, nee, die Botschaft muss jeder verstehen. Arschmond. Was für eine Botschaft soll das denn sein? Ja, dass er ein Arsch ist. Aber er denkt ja nicht aufs feinen Stück, ist aber ein Himmelskörper, der sich bewegt, nach den Gesetzen der Physik. Der zeigt uns ja auch immer nur seine Rückseite. Nein, seine Vorderseite. Nein, das ist eigentlich seine Rückseite. Das sagst du, Arschmond. Nein, das Gesicht ist auf der anderen Seite. Warum? Der Mond hat ein Gesicht, wurde doch gefunden von der Nase. Was für ein Gesicht? Der Mond hat ein Gesicht, da ist so ein Gesicht auf dem Mond. Mann im Mond. Und der ist ja, na, das will ich jetzt nicht wissen. Davon will ich überhaupt nichts wissen. Der zeigt uns den Hintern. So ist es, ist es wirklich so. Der könnte sich ja mal drehen, macht er nicht. Arschmond. Er kann weg von mir aus. Kann weg, Ebbebe und Flut, gäbe es Ebbe und Flut nicht. Niemand würde sagen, hä, scheiße, fuck, warum ist der Wasserspiegel immer gleich? Doch, Gezeitenkraftwerke. Warum ist das Wasserspiegel immer gleich? Fuck, Leute, warum ist es nicht hoch und runter, hoch und runter die ganze Zeit? Kein anderes Konzept ist so. Wenn du einen Wald anschaust, dann geht er nicht vor und zurück, vor und zurück, vor und zurück zu den Waldgrenzen die ganze Zeit. Nein, aber er bleibt, wo er ist. Ja, aber er verändert sich. Ja, aber er kommt nicht hundert Meter wieder vor, hundert Meter zurück den ganzen Tag. Der Wald funktioniert nicht wie das Meer. Und das ist gut so. Aber auch nicht jedes Meer hat das. So, ich wollte das auch jetzt nicht so früh im Jahr ansprechen, die ganze Mondthematik, weil ich weiß, dass du da ein bisschen aggressiv., aber das ist vielleicht auch, es gibt alles polarisiert, viele Themen polarisieren, bei uns der Mond, aber ich finde, wir müssen einen Common Ground finden. Und deswegen, ich finde es gut, dass wir da eine gesunde Streitkultur haben. Ja, das finde ich auch, also das finde ich, dass wir da respektabel miteinander umgehen. Ich habe mir einen Vorsatz genommen. Es ist ein Wunsch. Es ist kein Vorsatz, es ist ein Wunsch. Ich würde gerne sehen dieses Jahr 2025 und ich rede hier explizit mit allen Sketch-Autoren und mit allen YouTube-Comedians. Zwischenfrage? Ja. Ist die Kunst vom Sketch nicht tot? Nein. Und zwar geht es mir im weitesten Sinne um Imitationskunst. Und was ich gerne sehen würde, sind Imitationen von KI-Videos. Jeder kennt KI-Videos, dieses I've watched Lion King and KI ruined it. Und dann werden immer Szenen bis zu einem gewissen Punkt gespielt, und danach übernimmt die KI und macht ganz verrückte Dinge. Noch nie gesehen, aber okay. Und ich hätte das gerne, du kennst doch hier Olaf Scholz, der dann Rückwärtssalto macht und Schatten boxen und so. Der Papst, der dann die Klarre rausholt. Ganz genau. Und das hätte ich gerne gesehen, aber als Imitation. Also, dass Leute das imitieren. Weil es ist oft so, wenn bei KI-Videos Leute am Tisch sitzen, dann stehen die meistens auf, unnötigerweise, und die haben oft diese wellenhaften Bewegungen. Und diese sechs Finger. Die sechs Finger werden so hochgezogen und hängen unter der Decke und so. Und ich würde dieses Jahr gerne ein Video sehen von, ach meine Güte, Papa Platte, ja, Tomato Licks, ja, sowas in der Ecke, dass die mal irgendwie wirklich mal ihr Smartphone in die Hand nehmen und da ein Video machen, das imitieren. Weil wir haben jetzt noch diesen, glaube ich, diesen kurzen Korridor, der ist nicht mehr lang, wo KI-Video wirklich noch trashig schlecht ist. Und dann würde ich gerne das imitiert sehen, bevor es alles übernimmt und komplett alles kaputt macht. Aber diesen kurzen Moment würde ich gerne noch zelebrieren, bevor es vorbei ist. Vielleicht greifen das wegen die Aliens an, weil die merken, oh shit, da ist die KI-Revolution kurz bevor. Zerstören, zerstören, zerstören. Ja. Aber warum greifen sie ja nur die USA an? Das ist so komisch. Die sind, also was heißt angreifen, es gab noch keine Übergriffe, es gab nur diese Annäherungen, also diese ganzen Drohnen über New Jersey. Ich habe das hautnah verfolgt am Handy und habe gedacht, oh, jetzt geht es aber ganz schön wild. Vielleicht ist das einfach der erste Ort, also du musst ja gucken, die kommen ja von weit weg, fliegen auf die Erde zu und dann ist einfach der Deckel. Die denken, ah, da kommst du an. Das Gesicht der Erde. Wie wenn du in der Stadt ankommst, kommst du ja auch erstmal Ortseinfahrt. Du bist ja nicht direkt in der Mitte der Stadt. Und USA ist halt so die Ortseinfahrt der Erde, dass man da halt ankommt, wenn man halt aus dem gewissen Winkel kommt. Das ist ja halt die Abfahrt. Das ist wie die Abfahrt der Hyperraumroute. Genau, die Abfahrt geht halt erstmal zu den USA. Die müssen halt nur gucken, dass die nicht falsch rum landen. Das ist, denke ich auch. Weil die haben ja keine Ausrichtung. Und die landen dann so mit Kopf unten und dann geht die Tür so nach oben auf, die Lande-Rampe geht so nach oben auf und dann müssen die so hoch rausklettern. Die laufen falsch. Scheiße, die Schwerkraft ist falsch rum. Auf unserem Planeten ist die Schwerkraft andersrum. Bei uns werden alle nach oben gezogen. Das ist so, ich erinnere mich immer an Harmontown, wo Rob Schraub mal gesagt hat, warum fliegen wir immer nach oben? Warum fliegen wir immer nach oben? Warum fliegen wir immer nach unten? Das Universum, wir fliegen immer nach oben. Niemand fliegt mal einfach nach unten fliegen. Ja, das ist ein sehr berechtigter Punkt. Ich finde, das ist so ein berechtigter Punkt. Dass du wirklich wie so ein Hecht machst. Also von der Erde, du fliegst los und machst dann so ein Hecht nach unten. Oder einfach von unten starten. Wo ist das Problem? Einfach mal nach unten. Was ist unten? Aber machen das nicht die Inde? Die Inde haben doch jetzt auch ein Raumfahrprogramm. Die sind rechts, die sind leicht rechts. Ja, die fliegen ja rechts. Irgendjemand muss auch nach rechts fliegen. Und ich sehe die Teleskope, wie sie immer nach oben gucken. Ja, die sehen nichts. Ihr seht nichts. Idioten. Und dann suchen sie da, ah krass, der nächste Planet ist hier im Alpha-Centauri-System. Wir gucken nach oben, Approxima Centauri. Ja, vielleicht ist unter uns die nächste Sonne recht nah. Es ist sehr berechtigt. Es ist wirklich sehr berechtigt. Genau wie bei Star Wars Episode 2, wo da geht es ja auch darum, dass dieser Planet weg ist aus.
Attack of the Clones.
Attack of the Cloners. Who cloned those Cloners? Geht nicht bei Camino. Genau, da ist ja dieser Planet geheim, weil das Klonprojekt wird ja geheim gehalten und Obi-Wan Kenobi findet das Stück für Stück. Und dann kriegt er irgendwie, schaut er diese Sternenkarte an und dann sagt er, hm, von den Anziehungskräften müsste hier eigentlich ein Planet sein, südlich des sowieso-Zyklus. Südlich? Also einen Planeten zu beschreiben als südlich? Ja, George Lucas in der ersten Reihe. Genau, wie ich es immer verstanden habe. Erstmal, Jar Jar, gibt es da, weil ich finde den mega gezogen. Keine Fragen zu Jar Jar, auch kein Lob, es könnte auch loblos werden. Weil, also ich habe das Gefühl, es wurde so angekündigt als Kritikrunde oder Fragerunde, aber es kann auch Lob. Ich glaube, niemand hat Lob, ich glaube, niemand hat irgendeine Wortmeldung zum Thema. Na, wie ich es verstanden habe immer, ist, dass es ein Doppelsonnensystem ist. Weißt du? Weißt du? Ach so, ich verstehe nicht. Es gibt ja sehr viele Systeme, Sonnensysteme, die haben Planeten, wie wir um die Sonne drehen, nur halt, dass die um zwei Sonnen drehen, die sich selber umeinander drehen. Und die drehen manchmal richtig, die haben so crazy Umlaufbahnen, dass sie immer zur Mitte schneller werden und dann wieder auseinandergerichtet werden, sich aber doch auch anziehen und so, weil die Masse so gross ist, dass sie wieder zusammenbleiben.
Und da könnte man an der Laufbahn erkennen, wenn sich dann eine kleine Sonne bewegt, dass da eine Sonne fehlt. Da könnte man anhand dieser einen Sonne sagen, ah hier, alles leute darauf hin, dass da eine andere Sonne wäre. Das verstehe ich alles. Ich hänge mich nur an der Formulierung auf, dass wir dann hier sagen, hier müsste was sein, südlich des Omikronsystems. Ah ja, ja, weil das sind zweidimensionale System. Und wenn man über Planeten redet, also was soll genau südlich wovon sein? Aber auch hier als Filmemacher, George Lucas, mein Kollege, würde ich sagen, völlig richtig, das so zu formulieren, weil der Zuschauer checkt's. Ich hätte gerne mal, dass diese Balls niemand hatte von den neuen Regisseuren von der neuen Star Wars Trilogie, dass mal jemand einen Wochentag droppt, dass er nicht so lustig gefunden ist. Und dann sagt er so, Donnerstag warst du doch auf Camino. Also machen wir nächste Woche Donnerstag. Also machen wir nächste Woche Dienstag. Aber es ist Freitag. Obi-Wan, Obi-Wan, heute ist Freitag. Heute ist der Kuchen auf mich, Obiwan, es ist Freitag. Aber das wäre, also warum nicht, das wäre so lustig, weil einfach alles normal, wie es immer ist, und so Star Wars, und dann irgendwann drückt sich einfach so ein Wochentag da durch. Vor allem bei Star Wars gibt es zu allem einen Jedipedia-Artikel, Wikipedia-Artikel, egal bei wem. Und da würde ich einfach das reinschreiben, um diese Leute zum Rotieren zu bringen, die plötzlich denken, okay, wir müssen die gesamte Geschichte von Star Wars in Wochentage einteilen. Wann war die Schlacht um, ja, wie in vier, es war ein Mittwoch, einfach so jeden Tag. Mitten in der Woche haben die da angegriffen. Es macht ja auch manche Sachen ein bisschen anders.
Das finde ich gut. Aber deswegen, dass ihr mir dieses Jahr ein bisschen auf den Mond achtet und den nicht so versteht. Aber gib uns konkrete, weil ich habe, das war mein Problem mit Vorsätzen, das immer, man macht grobe Vorsätze, aber hält sich nicht dran. Ich möchte konkrete Punkte, Termine, konkrete ... Radisch mit dem Mond umzugehen. Aber hat der Mond, aber hängt der Mond dann ... Luna Lunaris. Nein, das ist Bullshit. Das ist ein Scherz. Okay, okay, der war nicht schlecht. Ich weiß. Aber kann man da nicht auch einfach sagen, der Mond kreist um die Sonne, halt nur unangenehm nah an uns? Der ist gar nicht unser Buddy, unser Mond. Der umkreist uns auch. Genau, also er umkreist uns auch kreisförmig. Und das geht er nicht in die Hirne rein. Aber da würde ich mir wünschen, dass wir da mal ... Okay, aber du sagst immer, du würdest wünschen, was konkret. Also kann man sagen, ich würde gerne mit dir noch mal irgendwie im März noch mal reinkommen und gucken, wie läuft es mit deinem Vorsatz. Weil ich möchte dir gerne helfen. Ich will dir helfen. Okay, merke ich nicht. Weil du hast bis jetzt alle Vorsätze über Bord geworfen, relativ kurz vor der Halle-Gedrill-König.
Und deswegen würde ich gerne dieses Mal dir helfen, bei deinem Vorsitz. Weil du hast bis jetzt alle Vorsätze über Bord geworfen, relativ kurz vor Halle-Gedrill-Könige. Und deswegen würde ich gerne dieses Mal dir helfen. Das ist mein Vorsatz. Ich möchte anderen Menschen bei ihren Vorsätzen helfen. Und ich möchte, dass du mir konkrete Punkte gibst, die ich überprüfe an gewissen Terminen. Dass du mir sagst, wenn du sagst, ich will nicht mehr rauchen, das frage ich, ich komme in zwei Wochen nochmal und frage, hast du geraucht, warum, was kann ich machen, wie können wir das angehen, ja, ich bleibe dran, das gesamte Jahr, das gesamte Jahr, ich bleibe das gesamte Jahr an dir dran und ich helfe dir, wie, ganz genau, und deswegen, sagen wir mal, 19. März, was kann ich konkret machen? Ich möchte nicht in die, und ich bin oft in die Falle in meiner Vergangenheit getappt, dass ich hochgucke mal wieder und denke, ah, der umkreist uns.
Was für ein, was für ein kleiner, ja, Wicht.
Sag's, so, guck mal, Aura Neiger.
Mach mal was Eigenes, nochmal was Eigenes.
Und jetzt, inzwischen habe ich verstanden, nee, das ist meine wiederum sehr ignorante Wahrnehmung, eigentlich kreist er in einem Kreis um die Sonne. Wir sind nur auch da und darum kreist er uns auch. Auf der Art ist das noch cooler. Wir umkreisen nur die Sonne. Und deswegen ich möchte, und ich bin immer wieder in die Falle getappt, dass ich denke, ach, kleiner Wicht. Und jetzt, das möchte ich nicht mehr. Frag mich also am 19. März, hast du an den Himmel geguckt und nimmst du den Mond,
als das war, was er ist, nämlich ein wunderschöner Gesteinsbrocken,
der in einer ebenbürtigen Bahn kreisförmig um die Sonne kreist.
Venus?
Cuncarrus.
Okay.
Ich habe das Gefühl, wir machen wenig mit unseren, also so die Planeten sind ja wie Brüder,
der Mond ist so ein Cousin oder so. Und jetzt als Venus will ich mir denken, warum hängt der ständig mit einem Cousin rum und nicht mit mir. So bei Cousins weiß man immer nicht, so dürfen die, ist es nah, also jetzt nicht in dem Sinne, aber es ist einfach, ich meine muss ja, also rein statistisch muss ja. Hm? Die muss ja. Es ist ja mathematisch, also ... Du musst mit der ...
Also, na ja, du hast also ... Du musst mit der ...
Also, na ja, du hast zwei Eltern.
Die wiederum haben auch zwei Eltern.
Jede Generation so.
Ja, du meinst, statistisch hat man ...
Genau, wenn du jetzt 30 Generationen hochgehst, hast du 10 Milliarden.
So viele Menschen gab's nicht.
Vor 30 Generationen.
Ja.
Also es muss, also ich ...
Also klar, klar ist es gesellschaftlich nicht ideal, aber ich meine, es war Weihnachten. Hast du mal die Bilder von den späten Habsburgern gesehen? Naja, aber das ist ja auch eine Art Mode. Irgendwann, ich kann ja auch nicht aufhören, da hinzugucken, also diese Bilder, die dann von, entweder dachte ich mir auch schlechte Maler.
Ja, das ist natürlich das Problem, wenn du nicht genug Geld hast. Ich meine, ich stelle mir immer so die alten Könige im Mittelalter vor, die wirklich nichts, wirklich gar nichts gegen die Künstler damals, aber wirklich hier so Strichmännchen-Scheiss einfach bekommen haben. Also die Belagerung von Jerusalem oder whatever so, Istanbul, Konstantinopel gedöns und dann wirklich lächerlich und paar hundert Jahre später einfach diese perfekten Renaissance-Gemälde, wunderbar und dann denkst du dir, ich habe die fucking halbe Welt erobert und das bin ich oder was so, warum, oh Mann! Ach, die Osterinselstatuen, einfach so süße Köppe, so süße Köppe, so Comic-Köppe. Die alle genau bis zum Hals unter der Erde waren. Ja, ja. Also klar, nee, stopp, Erosion, Erosion ist eh, ist eh ein Thema, wo ich nicht drinstecke, gar nicht, aber genau bis zum Hals? Erosion ist 2026, du greifst vor. Machen wir 2026 das Jahr der Erosion, dann handeln wir das alles komplett ab. Genau, ich rufe aus. 20, Mond, Jahr, Jahr des Mondes. Jahr des Mondes, finde ich gut. Arschmoll. Arschmoll, ja, finde ich gut. Ich habe jetzt auch herausgefunden, warum ich den Januar und Februar und so immer allzu sehr depressing wahrnehme. und es liegt auch an mir, weil ich habe immer so überlegt, wenn ich jetzt das Jahr in die Jahreszeiten einteilen müsste. Und ich meine nicht die meteorologischen Jahreszeiten, die nachgewiesenerweise, da ist Herbstanfang, da ist Sommer, die meine ich nicht, sondern wie ich denke, wann der Winter anfängt.
Ja, ja.
Und der Winter hört bei mir, Mitte Januar ist der vorbei.
Ja.
Also wenn ich, ich würde dich gleich auch immer fragen, wie dein Jahr aussieht, weil es ist bei jedem anders.
Ich habe das auch mal im Freundeskreis gemacht, weil ich dachte irgendwann, ja klar, ich nehme den
Februar ist für mich, obwohl
es tiefster, tiefster, tiefster Winter ist,
ist für mich Februar
Frühling, aber auch schon tiefer Frühling.
Ah, okay. Ja, ich glaube,
das Kernproblem ist einfach das verfrühte
Weihnachten, dass das Weihnachten nicht mehr
richtig im Winter liegt, dass das nicht mehr
funktioniert und du danach eigentlich
keinen Bock mehr hast, so, dass du irgendwie danach noch zwei Monate mit der Mütze rumlaufen musst und eigentlich denkst du, innerlich ist es schon vorbei. Ich glaube, und da appelliere ich den Papst, dass man sagt, Weihnachten im Februar. Ich habe nämlich gesagt, also Mitte Januar ist Frühlingsanfang. Sommer fängt recht früh an, so am Mai. Mai ist hardcore Sommer. Aber deine Jahreszeiten sind auch nicht alle gleich lang. Nein, nein, überhaupt nicht. Also Winter ist so drei Wochen lang. Das fällt einem ja auf. Sommer fängt so, genau, so April, Mai ist Sommer. Der geht bis Ende September. Und dann ist Oktober und November ist Herbst. Okay, nur zwei Monate? Ganz kurz. Also Herbst ist super kurz, Winter ist auch sehr kurz. Dafür ist Sommer das halbe Jahr bei dir. Halbe Jahr. Und deswegen, es führt auch dazu, dass ich super oft denke, wo wäre ein scheiß Sommer? Weil ich aber auch diese Ränder, die gar nicht Sommer sind, aber in meinem Kopf sind es Sommer. Und ich glaube, es ist einfach nur falsch abgespeicherte Assoziationen. Gibt es in jeder Kultur vier Jahreszeiten? Weiss ich nicht. Weil das finde ich schon erstaunlich, also dass es da nicht andere Kulturen gibt, die sagen, ja klar, Frühling, Sommer, Wörner, Herbst und Winter. Fünf Jahreszeiten, klar, war schon immer so. Wörner, Wörner. Ja, Frühling, Sommer, Wörner, Herbst, Winter. Wörner, Wörner. Wörner, genau. Wo ist das? Die Zeit, wo die Schmetterlinge fliegen. Sommer. Ja, das ist zwischen Sommer und Herbst. Wörner. Wörner, ja. Wie lange ist Wörner? Wörner drei Monate. Drei Monate? Genau, wie die anderen Jahreszeiten auch. Alle sind drei Monate. Alle drei Monate, ja. Alle, du hast fünf aufgezählt. Fünf Monate. Also 15 Monate gibt es bei euch. 15 Monate hat ein Jahr. Okay, dann gehen wir mir Monate durch. Januar, Februar, März, April, Mai, Juni, Juli, August, fünf Oktober, Dezember. Wörner ist auch ein Monat? Wörner ist auch ein Monat, ja. Was? Ja klar. Hä, das war bei uns schon immer so. Wörner, Karumo und Yondel. Wondel. Wörner, Karumo und Yondel. Das sind die letzten Monate. Wörner, Karumo und Mondel, Januar, Februar, März. Yondel. Okay, aber die fallen jetzt nicht in den, Wörner liegt gar nicht in Wörner. Nee, nee, nee. Ihr merkt selber, das ist ein wahnsinnig Quatsch. Nee, das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen. Also das haben wir wie gesagt, wie ich seit klein auf kenne ich das so.
Wo kommst du her?
Berlin Erde.
Ach so.
Also Deutschland, Europa.
Du?
Wir kommen aus Bhutan.
Wir.
Ja, wir haben eine ganze Familie.
Ah, okay, ich dachte, das ist auch so eine Art zu reden.
Nee, nee, also wir im Sinne von ich.
Nee.
Ich habe nur bis elf meinen Parkautomaten bezahlt.
Ich müsste jetzt, ich müsste bald los.
Ich meine nur, ich habe bis elf ...
Muss er nicht los, es ist drei.
Es ist zehn vor elf.
Zehn vor elf. Ich habe bis ...
Was ist denn das für eine Uhr?
Ja, 30 Stunden hat der Tag.
Ach du Schande.
Wir fahren nie wieder nach Bhutan.
Kann ja sein, dass es andere Kulturen gibt.
Ich meine, wir denken immer aus dieser Stefan-zentrischen Perspektive.
Genau, genau, genau.
Das ist mein Reden.
Immer wieder aus der Stefan.
Also wirklich, als würde ich mir so einen Fleischanzug, wie so einen Astronautenanzug, so einen Stefan-Fleischanzug anziehen, aus deinen Augen gucken und ich sehe die Welt nur als Stefan.
Okay, ja, aber.
Ekelhaftig.
Warum ekelhaft?
Es ist einfach ekelhaft, weil es so warm und irgendwie ist es.
Sag mal wie du die, jetzt ohne gross nachzudenken, wann Sommer anfangen ist, wann Herbst anfangen ist, sag mal deine, okay, wo sind deine Anfänge der Jahreszeit? Ja, ich mache das an konkreten Ereignissen fest. Peak Winter ist Weihnachten. Winter fängt an, wenn ich alle Geschenke gekauft habe. Das kann teilweise auch 25. Dezember sein. Okay, also Mitte Dezember fängt der Winter an. Genau. Dann Frühling beginnt, sobald ich die ersten Vögel zwitschern höre.
Also Ende Februar.
Sommer beginnt, sobald ich den Termin für meinen Sommerurlaub habe, sobald ich mich darauf freuen kann, sobald ich genau weiss, wie viele Tage mache.
Teilweise im Jahr davor.
Was dann kompliziert wird, weil das überlappende ...
Ja, ja, ja. Okay.
Genau. Und Herbst, sobald die Blätter
fallen. So merke
ich mir das immer. So mache ich das bei mir.
Ja, der Herbst hat mich auch noch nie enttäuscht.
Weil der Sommer,
weil der so kurz ist.
Der ist so kurz. So wie zu 20 Minuten bei dir.
Der ist wirklich ganz kurz. Aber es stimmt, ja.
Rein, raus, ist eine Übergangs
Jahreszeit. Nee, der braucht
es eh. Also ich glaube, klar, wenn du jetzt sagst, 25 Mond, 26 Erosion, ich würde mal 27 reservieren für Kalender 2.0.
Lass uns den Kalender wirklich nochmal angucken, Jahreszeiten, Feiertage, nochmal kompletten Strich drunter, wirklich nochmal kompletten Kreuz durch und zu gucken, wann, was sind sinnvolle Jahreszeiten, wann sollte Weihnachten sein, wann sollten Feiertage sein, können wir ein paar Pfingstlieder kriegen, verdammt noch mal! Pfingsten, Pfingsten, Hallo Pfingsten, Hallo Pfingsten, Hallo Pfingsten, Hallo Pfingsten, hallo Pfingsten, hallo Pfingsten. Was ist noch für ein Lied? Das ist California, aber es ist ein Lied halt. Es ist ein Lied. Pfingsten der Staat, der amerikanische Staat. Du kannst alles mit California machen. Stefan Tietze, Stefan Tietze, Stefan Tietze. Du kannst alles mit California machen. Es ist fantastisch. Es ist der beste Song aller Zeiten. Ja, ich habe neulich einen Kalender gesehen, hat wer vorgestellt im Internet, einen Kalender, der nicht links Montag und rechts Sonntag hat, sondern so fließt. Also der hat zum Beispiel eine Zehner, zehn Spalten. Und dadurch fängt nicht jeder Montag ganz links an. Und das hat so viel gemacht, lustigerweise, weil du nicht diese Einheiten hast, die mal irgendwann jemand gemacht hat, sondern du siehst, ah, wenn du Urlaube planst oder sowas, du checkst viel mehr, wie es wirklich ist und wie es sich anfühlt. Und nur zum Beispiel, Kalender fangen ja dann auch immer am ersten an, das heißt, irgendwann hört die Woche auf und dann fängt das an. Und diese Tage sind sehr weit auseinander, das nächste Spalt, das nächste Absatz. Obwohl es direkt der nächste Tag ist. Und dadurch wirken Urlaube viel länger als sie sind, wenn du die mal so in deinem Apple-Kalender einträgst. Ah, der Übersprung. Der Übersprung. Der Zeilensprung. Genau. Durch den Zeilensprung fühlen sich Urlaube länger an. Nein, nein, sie sehen länger aus im Kalender und sind kürzer, würde ich sagen. Sie fühlen sich kürzer an, sie sehen. Wenn du sagst, so drei Quadrate und dann vier noch in der nächsten Zeile, im Gegensatz zu sieben nebeneinander. Ich bin einen halben Monat weg. Ja, stimmt. Ich bin den ganzen Herbst weg. Stimmt. Aber in Wahrheit bist du nur fucking vier Tage und da ist ein Monatwechsel drin. Warum denn von allen Zahlen für die Woche die fucking sieben? Sechs, okay, acht, ja. Die sieben, das ist die schlimmste Zahl. Niemand kann siebener einmal eins, du kannst sieben durch nichts zahlen, sieben ist eine Primzahl, du kannst nichts damit machen. Warum musst du die Woche teilen? Warum musst du immer alles teilen? Warum sind Primzahlen Hot Take? Primzahlen sind überbewertet, völlig überbewertet. Ist doch geil zu teilen. Weil du die Riemann-Hypothese nicht lösen konntest in deinem einwöchigen Aufenthalt auf so einer Almhütte. Wurde jetzt gelöst, angeblich von so einem TikToker. Aber das war mir dann zu langweilig. Der hat nämlich den TikTok-Feed nicht nach unten gescrollt, sondern nach oben gescrollt. Da kommt der geile Scheiß. Der richtig geile Scheiß. Und irgendwann kam die Lösung für die Riemann-Hypothese. Da dachte sich, Leute, hat das noch niemand gefunden? Hat tatsächlich noch niemand gefunden. Der kam aus Bhutan. Da liest man nämlich von unten nach oben. Ich glaube nur tatsächlich, dass sowas unsere Köpfe mal ein bisschen freier machen würde. Und dann können wir vielleicht gemeinschaftlich die Riemann-Hypothese lösen. In keiner grossen Arbeitsgruppe meinst du, dass wir uns alle mal zusammensetzen in so einem Gemeindehaus? Unsere Pufo-Arbeitsgruppe ist, wir rütteln an den Säulen, auf denen unsere Glaubenssätze aufgebaut sind. Zum Beispiel Kalender ist, stellt euch das Jahr als ein, wie stellst du dir zum Beispiel Jahre vor? Sind das so Blöcke oder eigentlich, wie es ist, ein langer Strahl? Nein, machen wir nicht. Wie so ein Sackmurmeln. Was hast du, so ein neues Problem. Wenn ich Neujahrsfeier, zehn, neun, acht, denke ich mir so, Alter, ich habe jetzt einen ganzen Sackmurmeln. Der ist so unüberblickbar, du hast so richtig so, wenn du den drückst, das knarcht, so Glas an Glas, knarcht, knarcht in alle Richtungen und du denkst dir, wie viel fucking Murmeln soll er drin? Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich kann das nicht überblicken, das ist so viel, das ist so viel. Und am Ende des Jahres hast du wie viele genug? Am Ende des Jahres habe ich nur so drei Murmeln da und die sind so ganz abgegriffen. Also hast du 369, nein, 359, nein, nein, du kannst nicht die Murmeln vom letzten Jahr in den neuen Beutel tun, keine Chance. Das Problem ist, am Ende des Jahres hast du noch so drei Kugeln in dem Netz für 365, die sind komplett verloren. Die sind da unten noch irgendwie beim Gekrümel drin oder sowas drin. Deswegen, so stelle ich mir das vor. 356 hat das. Ja, genau. Das finde ich nämlich spannend, weil ich glaube, allein wenn man sich das Jahr mal anders vorstellt, wie du jetzt. Finde ich kreativ, finde ich cool. Ich glaube, dann kann was passieren. Und wenn wir Kalender uns anders vorstellen, kann ich mir vorstellen, ey, dann passiert was mit uns. Unsere Köpfe werden freier für das, um was das eigentlich geht. Okay, das wäre dann 2028 oder was? Also nochmal anders? Ja, genau. Das können wir in einem Atemzug machen mit diesen Jahreszeiten. Also sagen wir mal, die Perspektiven ändern. Wenn du mal sagst, oh Stefan,
wollen wir uns diesen Apfel teilen?
Ja, meine
Reaktion wäre, nein, nein, nein,
nein, nein, fick dich, nein, warum
hol doch einen eigenen Apfel?
Und die neue Perspektive wäre jetzt,
den Apfel zum Beispiel zu drehen.
Genau, und dann, ich würde den Apfel
auch nicht, wie man es normalerweise machen würde, von oben
schneiden, sondern ich würde ihn horizontal in der Mitte durchschneiden. Und ist dann das obere Teil besser oder der untere Teil? Von dem Apfel? Ja. Aber oben. Oben? Oder Stängeln ist? Unten hast du diesen Arsch, diesen Apfel-Arsch. Ja, was denn oben? Also ist ja die Frage, ne? Ja, aber das kann man gut drum herum essen. Drum herum essen. Aber du hältst es dann auch fest an einem Stängel? Dann kannst du von der Seite rum essen. Du hältst es fest wie so ein Becken. Wie ein was? Wie ein Becken, also das Musikinstrument Becken, was du so ding ding ding ding mit so einem Faden oben hältst. Ich war bei Wasser, war ich jetzt Becken. Nein! Nein! Okay, das finde ich gut. Perspektiven wechseln, das finde ich cool. Perspektiven, wir klingen wie so der philosophische Rutsch ins neue Jahr. So ein Live-Coach, das ist ja immer mein Lieblings, wenn ich auf Instagram so die Reels durchschaue, so die Life-Coaches, die so zwei Likes haben. Das finde ich die besten. Und dann schaue ich auch oft auf deren Kanäle und die haben wirklich hunderte Videos, zwei Likes, drei Likes, ein Like und die wirklich so, ey, glaub an dich, du kannst es schaffen, der Erfolg, du kriegst es einfach hin und es ist so toll, weil die so drin sind. Ich mache überhaupt nicht lustig. Aber schau mal. Nee, im Gegenteil. Ich finde das beeindruckend, dass du trotz
ausbleibendem Erfolgs denkst,
okay, ich habe hier eine Botschaft, ich kann den Leuten helfen.
Und wenn ich nur zwei Leuten helfe,
die machen es ja nicht für ihren Erfolg,
sondern die machen es vielleicht für die zwei Leute, die es liken.
Und die eine Person, die kommentiert. Das finde ich geil.
Ich finde es lustig, wenn es zwei Leute haben es geliked.
Und das ist irgendwie
weiß ich nicht,
Warren Buffett und ein anderer super erfolgreicher, reicher Mann oder Frau. Aber es ist so lustig, wenn du lachst so, der hat nur zwei. Was ist für ein Live-Code, der hat nur zwei Likes immer. Ach so. Da guckst du, was es für Likes sind und die sind so über erfolgreich. Jesus hätte auch zwei Likes gehabt. Genau, nee, zwölf. Zwölf Likes. Judas liked nicht. Stefan, das macht er nicht. Das macht er nicht. Ich habe keinen Account, Leute. Mann, ich habe mir halt keinen Instagram-Account gemacht. Das heißt doch nichts. Das heißt doch nichts. Hä, nur weil ich jetzt den Post von Jesus nicht geliked habe? Hey, Leute, hört doch mal auf, Mann. Ich habe halt keinen Instagramer. Ich nutze es halt nicht, Mann. Hä, heisst doch jetzt nicht, dass ich den irgendwie hintergehen will oder so. Hä, Leute, ich check's grad gar nicht, Mann. Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry. Hey, warte mal, ey, Paulus, Mann, was soll denn das gerade, Mann, ey? Ja, folgendes. Mann, ey, ich check's grad gar nicht, Mann, ich check's grad nicht. Du bist ja auch nicht auf Snapchat, Mann, ich bin halt mehr so auf TikTok unterwegs. Alles klar, wir haben das Gefühl, du passt nicht mehr so richtig zur Gruppe. Hä, Mann, ich check's grad gar nicht, ey. Wie, nur weil ich jetzt keinen Instagram-Account habe, oder was? Wir haben halt das Gefühl, alle, dass wir uns ein bisschen auseinandergelebt haben. Hä, ich check das überhaupt nicht alle elf, oder was? Alle elf, genau. Zwölf mit Jesus, oder was? Alle, genau, mit Jesus sind wir zwölf, die jetzt gemeinschaftlich denken. Hä, ich check's überhaupt nicht. Okay, ja, vielleicht erst mal beruhigen.
Ich check's gerade gar nicht, Mann.
Null Checkung gerade einfach.
Null Checkung, genau.
Wirklich komplett.
Komm, nimm dir erst mal hier einen Wein, einen Schluck Wein vom Jesus.
Genau.
So, erst mal durchatmen.
Wir haben sehr viel Fisch und Brot über.
Ja, Mann, ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf Fisch, ey. Das, ey. Und dann wollten wir einfach sagen... Warum ist es Forelle so? Nimm doch Lachs oder einen geilen Fisch oder so. Du bist halt auch viel am Rumkritisieren so. Hä? Ich versuche es halt besser zu machen. Ich versuche halt den nächsten... Ich versuche uns halt voranzuficken irgendwie so ein bisschen. Ich versuche uns halt auf den nächsten Level zu ficken gerade. Ja, diese Ausdrucksweise.
Weil ich habe das Gefühl, dass wir halt schon hinterher hängen irgendwie so.
Das passt halt gar nicht zu uns.
Mann ey, hast du mal gesehen, was die ganzen Juden machen so?
Die haben geile Leute, die haben geile Bücher, die haben geile Feste.
Wir haben Forellen, Mann.
Wir haben den König der Juden.
Jesus ist der König der Juden.
Ja, das check ich auch nicht.
Warum auch nicht?
Ganz ehrlich.
Warum sind wir dann was anderes? Auch nicht. Check, sind wir ja nicht. Sind wir das Gleiche, oder? Ja. Ich dachte, wir sind Christen. Ne, wir sind erst nach Jesus Tod. Pst, hey Mark, ey, pst, ey. Ne, aber im Ernst, ey, aber. Du redest im Schlaf. Ne, gut, jetzt wo das Thema mal auf dem Tisch ist. Hey Mann, jetzt pack mal auf, Paulus. Wollen wir beide? Wir sind der neue Jesus, okay? Wir beide, Mann. Wir haben keine magischen Kräfte. Wir beide. Hat der auch nicht, Mann. Hat der auch nicht, Mann. Hat der auch nicht, Mann. Ich kann nicht so gut slide of hand. Ja, das mache ich, okay? Du machst die Schnüre, du machst die unsichtbaren Schnüre, Mann. Hey Mann, Paulus. Wir beide. Ja, ich weiss nicht, wir beide, Mann. Natürlich auch wieder Da Vinci Code gesehen, hab dann natürlich direkt danach wiedergesehen, hab auf dem Wikipedia-Artikel, weil ich gucke dann so, was da schon stimmt, und die Idee ist ja, dass irgendwie Jesus eine Frau war. In dem Wikipedia-Artikel steht einfach, was stimmt an Da Vinci Code, und dann steht da einfach so, nichts, gar nichts, tschüss, ciao. Wie stimmt was? Und es gibt ja, also Die Kerntheorie von Da Vinci Code ist ja,
Jesus war eine Frau, beziehungsweise das war eigentlich
Maria Magdalena in dem Abendmahlbild von Leonardo Da Vinci.
Das sind zwei ganz unterschiedliche Dinge.
So, und dann, doch, so, und eigentlich war das eine Frau.
Und dann steht da auch so, ja, warum?
Der heilige Grad ist auch eine Frau, war ja die Idee.
Nee, doch, ja, aber metaphorisch, metaphorisch. Ja, aber das ist ja Humbug, das ist ja Quatsch. So, und dann sagt man, nee, stimmt, die ist da dabei, glaube ich, Maria Magdalena, die, wo er sich so anschmiegt, Jesus, das stimmt nicht, Jesus ist dabei und daneben sitzt Maria Magdalena mit lange Haare und ein angedeuteter Busen. Ich habe mir das mal ganz genau angeguckt. Bullshit. Bullshit. Ich meine... Ich schuhe auch mal rein kurz. Naja, also es ist jetzt eine historische... Stefan, wir sind ja jetzt eine Art historische... Also wir machen das jetzt gar nicht sexuell oder so, sondern es geht ja jetzt einfach nur darum, historisch... Ich tu mir rein, Alter. Naja, aber es ist ja historisch... Alter, tue mir jetzt sowas von rein. Naja, also angenommen, es ist einfach nur ... Geil, zeig. Nee, nee, nee, nee, Quatsch. Ich meine jetzt einfach aus kunstwissenschaftlicher Analyse ist es ja relevant, wie der Künstler das dargestellt hat und so. Also wie das jetzt ist. Was ich lustig finde, möchte ich, dass es jemand dieses Jahr durchzieht von euch. Wenn ihr so ein Date habt oder irgendwie das zweite, dritte Date, es läuft darauf hinaus, dass ihr zu dir, euch geht, zu einem von euch. Und wenn ihr dann habt, hängt ihr so ein riesengroß ausgedrucktes Bild von Da Vinci's Abendmahl auf. Ausgedruckt? Ausgedruckt. So mit so Pinpoints. Mit zwanzig Diner-Vier-Seiten. Ja, und dann so viele so Latein-Dingern und dann so Pinnadeln und so Fragezeichen und dann macht ihr auch dieses V, was das Gefäß der Heilige Gral. Schaut euch den, das erinnere ich mich auch noch dran bei Da Vinci Code, dieses Schaut auf den Tisch, seht ihr ein Gefäß, oh nein, krass, erwartet man doch. Der Heilige Gartet man doch. Ein Bild von Tom Hanks. Genau, ein Bild von Tom Hanks, eine random Telefonnummer, was auch immer. Ja, so eine Fünf-Dollar-Schein, auch mit so einer Pinnnadel einfach. Oder genau, mit diesem allsehenden Auge. Für Notfälle. Auf jedem Dollar ist doch diese Pyramide, diese Illuminaten-Pyramide. Genau, ja, Illuminaten-Ding, ja. Die einfach auch so draufgepinnt und einfach so ein I am crazy, so eine I am crazy Wand und mal gucken, wie das Date reagiert. Was ich wichtig fände ist, wenn das Date das anspricht, das so, ah, das ist so, mach ich so nebenbei. Nebenprojekt. Genau, es ist, ah, ist egal. Also gar nicht so, sondern wirklich einfach so, ah, ist egal, egal, lass uns weiter. Geht nicht hin und sagt, ah, ist dir hier schon aufgefallen? Nee, nee, nee, sondern einfach wirklich so,
das ist einfach so nebenbei, das ist ein Hobby.
Genau, macht es mysteriös. Weil dieses
Bild, ich weiß nicht, was es mit dir
macht, aber mit mir macht es
mit mir macht das
Mysterium
der Zeit, das hat so
Galileo Mystery.
Kleiner, also im Hintergrund
sieht man drei Fenster,
keine Fensterladen, nichts,
also no bullshit, einfach Löcher in der
Vielen Dank. Leo Mystery. Und kleiner, also im Hintergrund sieht man drei Fenster, keine Fensterladen, nichts, also no bullshit, einfach Löcher in der Wand, einfach, boah, ein bisschen luftig, oder? Können wir die Fenster zumachen? Das frage ich mich aber häufig. Ich stelle mir immer Burgen mit Fenstern vor. Boah, ein bisschen kalt, oder? Ein bisschen, wie sagt man, Föhn. Wollen wir die Fenster zumachen? Wir haben keine Fenster. Ja, einfach, dass wir die Fensterleiten einfach zumachen. Wir haben keine Fenster, einfach Löcher an der Wand. Nee, aber es ist sau kalt. Es ist total kalt. Ja. Es zieht hier komplett durch. Willst du noch eine Decke haben? Kannst du mal eine Tunika? Tunika, Tunika, Tunika. Was ist die Musikart, was ist die Heimattonart und was ist das kleineück? Tuniker. Nur weil ich deine Subdominante bin, will ich jetzt nicht mehr Tuniker haben. Jetzt habe ich einmal im Schwarz gesagt, aber du kannst jetzt hier mal den Tuniker haben. Okay, dankeschön. Case, ist immer noch zu kalt? Nein. Die haben das ja mit Schweinefett gestopft. Bitte? Die haben das mit Schweinefett gestopft. Das ganze Fenster. Die hatten keine Türen, die haben das komplett mit Schweinefett gestopft. Wie, muss man sich das dreidimensional vorstellen? Die haben das komplett, also, stell dir Schwarten. Und jetzt... Den gibt es schon wieder das Wasser in uns. Ich muss abschlucken. Entschuldigung. Florentin redet über Essen. Ich weiß gerade nicht, ob es vorne oder hinten ist. Florentin red und zack, mundesvoll. Ich finde das so, ich liebe das,
weil es bei mir genauso. Also, Schwarten.
So, und dann stell dir vor, wie so ein Maurer werden die Schweineschwarten
so in das Fenster
so gestapelt
und dadurch wird es isoliert. Du hast ja
früher quasi alles mit Schweinefett quasi.
Warum dann hat man nicht einfach die Wand gelassen?
Warum musste man dann noch die Wand
vorher machen? Boah, ein bisschen warm hier drin, oder? Können wir ein Fenster aufmachen? Einfach ganz ins Gegendrücken. So stehst du jeden Morgen auf, ah, ein schöner neuer Morgen. Und dann wird alles raus. Und zwar so, dass man danach komplett alles nochmal neu machen muss. Es ist unpraktisch. Fällt den Burggraben runter, kullern da alle Schweineschwarten runter. Aber so war das früher. Die haben nur Bullshit gemacht im Mittelalter. Die haben nur Bullshit gemacht. So, ich gehe rein ins Bild von L.D.W. Der angeblichen Maria Magdalena. Was sagt dein, du hast jetzt auch schon den ein oder anderen Busen in deinem Leben angesehen. Ich erkenne beim besten Willen, und da meine ich so ein richtiger Wille. Ja, wir alle kennen den Willen. Mein kann ich kein erkennen. Kein Busen erkennen. Die sieht aus wie eine Frau, bin ich ehrlich doch. Ja, das stimmt schon. Ich finde es ja interessant, ich finde es ja spannend. Die ergibt das V. Ich finde es ja auch spannend, der kann auch sein. Das ist ein Tag. Haben wir mal alle Bilder von dumm Vinci durchgeguckt, ob da nicht überall so ein V drin ist? Ich finde es ja auch spannend, ich finde es auch geil, dass der Autor sich nicht dazu äussert, also dass der nie mal irgendwie auf dem blauen Sofa interviewt wurde, der Vinci, oder dass man da irgendwie mal so einen Artikel schreibt und mal guckt so, wer war da alles dabei, weiß man nicht. Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn, elf, zwölf, jeder hat zwei Brote bekommen. Das ist viel zu viel Brot. 24 Brote. Es liegt so viel Brot auf dem Tisch. Ey, das war wahrscheinlich… Brot nicht auf kleinen Tellern, sondern neben dem Teller. Es ist ja wahrscheinlich ein Sau ...
Also nichts gegen Jesus, aber der hat wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht so viel Geld springen lassen fürs Restaurant.
Und es ist so ein klassisches, ich stopfe euch mit Brot voll, damit ihr nichts Teures bestellt.
Moment, es stehen Gläser auf dem Tisch.
Durchsichtige Gläser stehen auf dem Tisch.
Aber hinten war kein Glas mehr für die Fenster?
Nee, du stapelst am Ende des Abends, stapelst du die Gläser, die Trinkgläser, stapelst du ins Fenster.
Und morgens ... Und morgens raus. Raus. Ein guter neuer Morgen. Nee, du stapelst am Ende des Abends, stapelst du die Gläser, die Trinkgläser, stapelst du ins Fenster.
Und morgens raus.
Ein guter neuer Morgen.
Aber es sind wirklich tatsächlich durchsichtige Gläser auf dem Tisch.
Das ist schon, na, das ist doch Metall, oder? Ist das Blech? Ist das Aluminium? Warum kann ich denn da in die Flüssigkeit reingucken?
Guck mal, das ist doch ein Glas.
Wenn du über Wasser laufen kannst, Stefan.
Guck dir das mal an.
Ja, ich sehe es, ist komisch. Hatten die zu Jesus-Zeiten noch keine Glasgläser, oder? So, debunked. Vielleicht spielt das einfach auch 2008. Das ist so ein Reenactment oder sowas. Ah, dumm Ding, Schihe. Aber ich sehe auch nicht nur eine Frau, sondern mindestens drei. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich meine, darfst du als Jünger keine Frau haben, oder was? Nee, sein. War das so eine Art Priesterding? Man darf als Jünger keine Frau sein. Ach so. Nee, das ist ja halt irgendwie, die Einladung zum Abendmahl ist ja plus eins, oder? Was war denn in dem Artikel, dann stand da drin, was war es? Ja, da stand, es ist offen. Also da war keine tatsächliche Lösung, sondern da heißt es ist offen und bis heute ungeklärt.
Die Frage ist natürlich auch, wer sitzt hinter der Kamera?
Also weil du hast ja, klar, du buchst einen grossen Tisch.
Wer sitzt da hinter?
Ach, sehr merkwürdig ist die alle auf der einen Seite.
Super unangenehm.
Ach nee, super unangenehm.
Ach nee, ja, ist ein Denkfehler.
Ja, er ist ein Denkfehler. Wieso, die sitzen alle auf einer Seite der Tafel. Okay. Er ist einfach so dumm, dumm Denkfehler. Kleiner Wikipedia-Funfact. Schiff des Theseus, sagt ihr was? Nee. Ist eine Metapher von einem antiken Philosophen, dass wenn du ein Schiff hast und du wechselst ein Teil aus, ein Brett, ist es ja immer noch das gleiche Schiff. Was aber, wenn du über die Jahre hinweg jedes einzelne Teil des Schiffs ausgetauscht hast. Wie bei so einem 747, bei so einer 747. Genau, ist es dann noch das gleiche Schiff. Die 747 des Theseus. Was ist die Essenz des Schiffes, ist es die Summe ihrer Teile, blablabla. Und der Wikipedia-Artikel zu Schiff des Theseus wurde seit seiner Erstellung so oft editiert, dass mittlerweile kein einziges Wort der ursprünglichen Fassung mehr verhandelt ist. Auf Spaß? Ich glaube nicht. Vielleicht auch auf Spaß, aber die Idee ist, alles wurde einmal ausgetauscht. Ist es noch der gleiche Artikel? Auch der Name? Der Name, das weiss ich nicht. Alles sehr wiss ich. Das ist Schiff und Schiff des Thesäus, aber das ist ein kleiner Funfact. Kann sein, dass da, es gibt ja Philosophie, Humoristiker, die ja dann auch sowas dann aktiv befeuern, die dann sagen so, gefällt mir sehr, dass wir austauschen. Aber was ist deine Antwort auf diese Frage? Ob es Maria Magdalena ist oder nicht? Nee, ab wann ist ein Schiff ein neues Schiff? Ich sag, Schiff ist Schiff. Schiff ist Schiff. Schiff ist Schiff, auf jeden Fall. Weil, ja, so eine Sieben für Sieben, diese teilweise sind diese Flugzeuge, in denen wir fliegen, sind ja teilweise einfach Flugzeuge aus den 80ern oder so. Wo man auch sagen kann, ja, wahrscheinlich, die werden gut gewartet, wurde schon viele Sitze sowieso ausgetauscht, gibt ja offensichtlich auch keine Raucherabteile mehr oder so, aber es ist schon, hat sich sehr viel verändert, viele Teile wurden ausgetauscht, vermutlich ist es auch jetzt wie 80 Prozent inzwischen überholt. Ja, oder die Sugarbabes oder so Bands, wo halt alle Mitglieder einmal ausgetauscht wurden.
Nee, die sind eben noch zum Glück.
Nein, die sind alle wirklichieder einmal ausgetauscht wurden. Gestorben, ja. Nee, die sind, die leben noch zum Glück.
Tagischen Autounfall. Nein, die sind alle wirklich alle noch kerngesund.
Mich kerngesund.
Also wirklich teilweise wirklich nicht.
Nee, guck mal nach, das ist ein Elis Mandela-Effekt, dass die noch leben.
Nein, nein.
Die sind eigentlich gestorben beim Otto-Unfall.
Nein, die sind nicht beim Otto-Unfall gestorben.
Das Red auch so rein, Herr Gestorben.
Otto hat damit nichts zu tun.
Otto-Unfall.
Die sind alle, die sind alle am Leben.
Alle am Leben.
Und die machen teilweise auch noch mit Solo-Projektem Musik.
Melanie C ist tot.
Nein, ist sie nicht.
Die leben.
Und es gibt Bilder.
Und da ist auch die Frage, sind es noch die Sugar Babes?
Aber ich würde sagen, ja.
Melanie C lebt noch?
Melanie C lebt.
Jetzt habe ich wirklich gedacht, dass sie tot ist. Nein, nein, nein. Melanie Thor Melanie Thornton ist tot. Nein, nein, nein. Ja, das kann sein, das kann sein. So. With Thorny unterwegs, das weiss ich nicht mehr. Melanie T. Melanie C. Nein, nein, nein, die sind alle unterwegs. Alle noch unterwegs. Gut. Ja, gibt es aber ein Revival dieses Jahr? Also welches Comeback wünschst du dir am meisten, als Rausschmeisser-Frage? Welches Comeback wünschst du dir am meisten dieses Jahr? A, Ernie und Bert, B, B, Otto Walkes, C, die Bloodhound Gang, oder D, Milli Vanilli. Ja, Milli Vanilli? Nervendig spannend einfach, was dann passiert. Wer singt? Der Tiger oder? Alles egal. Geben Sie sich noch Mühe. Also geben Sie sich mit Playback überhaupt noch Mühe. Moment, genau, die hatten diesen Plagiats-Playback. Die haben das Playback-plagiiert. Frank Fabian? Frank Fabian hat alles gesungen und der hat so Leute
unschön, weiß ich aber auch nicht mehr genau,
wie es war, krieg ich nicht mehr zusammen. Aber, ne,
Bloodhound Gang fände ich gut. Ah ja. Habe ich
gemocht als Teenie, als
rowdy Teenie.
Die waren so ein bisschen rebellisch,
raunchy, auch ein bisschen spicy.
Ich fand die auch immer sehr, sehr gut.
Passt gar nicht zu dir als Musik.
Nee, nee.
Aber, na ja. Hattest du nie so eine
rowdy, raunchy? Doch, ich war,
Das ist ein ganzes Wettbewerb. Ich fand die auch immer sehr, sehr gut. Passt gar nicht zu dir als Musik. Nee, nee. Aber, naja. Hattest du nie so eine Rowdy Ranchie? Doch, ich habe ja tatsächlich MTV, Bam Margera und so und wie war da Bam, so war ich immer dabei, auch wenn es nach außen überhaupt nicht meins ist. Bam and the Jammer, the Dammer, the Donuts, Ziggy, das waren, okay, cool. The Donuts,ankovision, all diese Geschichten. Butan und ich kommen nicht mehr zusammen heute. Nee, das kam ja alles so ein bisschen aus dieser Tony Hawk Skater Ecke. Ah, okay. Der erste Name, den ich kenne nicht. Und da gab es ja einiges. Aber du kamst ja nicht annähernd aus der Tony Hawk Skater Ecke. Null, null überhaupt nicht. Ich war eher so der kulturelle Beobachter, der sagt, ah, das ist ein Ausbruchsversuch aus den Elternketten. Aber auch eine interessante Geschichte bei Majerica, tatsächlich gibt es ein gutes YouTube-Video, Essay-Video, auch so 90 Minuten über die komplette Karriere, die Zeit damals, auch mit der Familie und allem Absturz, Wiederaufstieg, Recovery, Wiederabsturz, Wiederabstieg, Aufstieg, Abstieg, dann auch mal seitlich, also ganz, ganz spannende Sachen. Ich mag das ja so, Showbusiness, Filmchen. Okay, hinten raus alles eingerissen. Jetzt wirkt es so klein. Genau, das war mein Abstieg. Ich habe versucht, die Dramaturgie dieses Videos zu übernehmen. Finde ich ja richtig gut. Ben Majerik. Richtig, ja, Ben Maverick Majerik. Ben Jerik. Die Frage ist immer so, wird sowas auch mal über dich? Ich frage mich immer so, ich will dann auch mal in so einem Talking Head sitzen und dann so irgendwie der Fall Etienne Gade oder irgendwie sowas und da würde ich sagen, wir haben von nichts gewusst. Wir haben von nichts gewusst. Ich weiß noch, ich habe ihn kennengelernt und klar, Rückblicken, da gibt es total Sinn, aber damals
ich bin ja auch reingegangen
wirklich mit so einer, ja,
Bergkönig-Faszination.
Also du schaust da nach oben, du hast die
Glocken klingeln irgendwie, die
Schneeglöckchen überall, so du bist wirklich in so
einer Szene drin.
Ich will so reden, dass der Regisseur
sagt, können wir das nochmal machen? Einfach so, ja, ja, um Kopf und Kragen. Das ist nochmal. Ich möchte zwei Sachen dieses Jahr. Einmal in so einer Talking Heads, haben Sie davon gewusst, Sache, mich um Kopf und Kragen reden und Lügendetektortest möchte ich dieses Jahr auch noch haben. Weil ich, ganz ehrlich, manchmal weiß ich selber nicht, ob ich manche
Sachen glaube. Ob du selber lügst. Inzwischen geglaubt.
Das ist die Frage, der
Lügendetektor. Auf welcher Ebene checkt
er die Lüge? Ja. Wenn ich glaube,
dass ich lüge, oder weiss er
besser? Also weiss man, das ist die Frage,
weiss mein Körper, wann ich
lüge
und wann nicht.
Irgendwann lügt man ja so doll, dass man selber glaubt.
Die Fakten sprechen
eine andere Sprache, aber man selber glaubt das so doll.
Würde ich dann den Lügentrechter
überlisten oder
zuckt irgendeine Wimper von mir?
Der macht ja so Stresslevel oder so, ob du nervös bist.
Hoffentlich
merken die nicht, dass ich lüge.
So glaube ich, in die Richtung geht das.
Aber das kann man an sich schon machen. Das ist schon eine gute Idee. Ich mag das aber vor allem gerade bei solchen Dokumentationen, wenn du das ja Talking-Heads von verschiedenen Leuten. Und ich achte immer ganz besonders auf die Leute, die nur ein einziges Mal vorkommen. So Udo Littner, der war ja wirklich immer ein guter Freund von mir. Stark, stark, stark, wirklich keine Noten. Keine Noten. Der war ja immer ein guter Freund von mir. Perfekt. Und den Rest des Films kommt der nicht mehr vor. Ja. Weil du weißt natürlich, die haben wahrscheinlich eine gute Stunde mit dem gedreht. Mindest kostet. Vielleicht zwei. Als sie sind hingeflogen, oder sie sind da hingeflogen. Und alles, was sie benutzt haben von diesem zweistündigen Gespräch war, also der war ja eigentlich immer ein guter Freund von mir und danach nichts mehr. Und auch Udo Lindenberg schaut den Film und denkt sich, Leute, ich saß da am kompletten Nachmittag, hab alles, ja, also das Kinderhaus war ja auch immer ein bisschen traurig, also alles cut, cut, cut, cut, alles, alles weg. Was du laberst, ist egal. Alles weg. Man kann dir nicht zuhören.
Und es ist so tragisch, weil du nimmst ja von jedem von dem zwei Stunden auf.
Aber da kriegt man wenigstens mal.
Und am Ende hast du 30 Minuten für alle und musst aus zwölf Stunden 30 Minuten machen.
Und bei einem denkst du dann, der hat nichts gesagt, was nicht woanders auch schon vorkommt.
Von dem haben wir nur die, ja, ich bin der Udo Lindbergh, so und danach nichts.
Das ist mal ein objektives Zeichen, das man langweilig erzählt.
Ja, das kriegt man sonst oft ja wegen Höflichkeit nicht mit. These, Dokumentationen werden schwächer, weil alle so sehr mit dem Format Dokumentation schon jetzt sozialisiert sind, weil es so ganz viele Dokumentationen gerade gibt und so ein Riesen-Revival ja auch erlebt hat. Nee, glaube ich nicht. Dass alle in dem Bewusstsein
sind, dass sie schon genau wissen, wie sie da aussehen.
Dann werden sie besser. Und deswegen labern die...
Nee, es ist ja nicht...
Gut, was ist die...
Das Quartezmerkmal in der Dokumentation ist ja nicht, dass
die Leute spannender erzählen und im Sendebewusstsein,
sondern die fucking Wahrheit sagen.
Ich sag, du bist besser, wenn du weisst, was du tust.
Ich glaube nicht an Authentizität.
Ich möchte die beste True-Crime-Serie aller Zeiten empfehlen. Das ist ja jahr der authentizität flontin lass mich eine sache empfehlen für dieses jahr the jinx auf hbo eine der besten true crime dokumentation und die würde jetzt nicht mehr funktionieren weil er selber ich will nicht zu viel verraten aber das schaue ich mir jetzt direkt an was in den letzten zehn Sekunden der Serie passiert, ist atemberaubend. Schau ich mir jetzt direkt an. Und das würde nicht passieren. Ich schaue mir nur die letzten zehn Sekunden an. Das macht ja keinen Sinn. Ich schaue mir nur das Ende an. Ich schaue mir nur die letzte Minute an. Das ist wie, du hast die Pointe, aber die Feedline nicht. Das ist mir egal, ich will lachen. Ich schaue mir nur die letzte Minute an. Jesus, okay. Sonst nichts. Wir hören jetzt hier auf. Okay. Vielen Dank für dich, dass du die du Zeit gefunden hast. Gerne vielen Dank an Stefan Tietze, dass dein Fahrer dich hierher gefahren hat. Vielen Dank an Susi für das Intro. Schön, dass du da bist. Wir sehen uns auch im Jahr 2025 regelmäßig wieder. Schaut ab und zu in den Himmel. Schaut mal, ob ihr uns seht. Wir sind mit unserem Ufo immer auf der anderen Seite des Mondes, so dass der Mond uns noch nie gesehen hat.
Wir schauen ganz fest nach unten. Wir haben den unten im Blick. Macht euch da keine Sorgen.
Macht euch keinen Kopf. Macht's gut. Bis nächste Woche.
Schau ihr, macht's gut, hat rein.
Ich sag tschüss. Danke Stefan, tschüss.
Tschüss.
It's a worst bird production. Immer noch in 2024? It's a fucking worst bird production. Es ist eine Schmerzproduktion.
Immer noch in 2024?
Es ist eine Schmerzproduktion. Willkommen im Ruhrgebiet. Echt statt inszeniert. Jede Ecke anders, jede Story echt. Späti-Romantik an der Trinkhalle, Beats unterm Förderturm, Sonnenuntergang auf der Halde. Klingt anders? Ist es auch. Dein Ruhrgebiet, wo das Unperfekte perfekt passt. Inspiration für deinen Next-Level-Städtetrip gibt's auf Insta, mein.ruhrgebiet.